what's going on guys this is rob and i
was drinking my morning cup of coffee
and i was reading the x-men comics and
then it just boom occurred to me out of
nowhere i think marvel comics just gave
us the origin to thanos and mutants in
the marvel cinematic universe and i
think eros is the key to understanding
it so here's what we're going to do if
you guys want to know the full on origin
if you guys want to be experts on x-men
mutations all that kind of stuff i'm
going to link a playlist down in the
description that will send you over to
comics explain and make you an expert on
everything related to the x-men but for
the purpose of this video i'm going to
give you guys the quick and dirty
explanation in terms of how mutations
used to work because you have to
understand that to understand what i'm
going to tell you here in a second and
how it rolls over into the marvel
cinematic universe and how eros and
everything ties into it so why the clock
back to the early days in marvel comics
right and the way that the mutant origin
was explained to us was simply saying
that mutation was a result of genetic
modification at the hands of the
celestials that in the early days of
earth the celestials showed up on earth
and they modified a portion of humanity
called the wanderers the idea was that
this genetic modification led to the
creation of the eternals it led to the
deviance and then it led to the genetic
modification of some of these humans so
that at some future point in time they
would start developing powers and so the
idea behind mutants in marvel comics for
decades has always been that they were
just the evolutionary next step right
they didn't really know at least in the
early days they didn't know that
celestials were responsible or the ones
that caused their mutation in the first
place guys like gabriel shepard the
proto-mutants things like that basically
brought all this to light fighting the
dreaming celestial and so on and so
forth a lot of this has been explained
over the years and the x-men are aware
of their heritage regarding the
celestials nowadays what marvel is doing
now though is they're changing this what
they're saying and this really comes by
way of the current judgment day event
which we're covering over comics explain
what they're doing is they're changing
the origin of mutants and referring to
it as something called excess deviation
in effect mutations as they exist in
marvel comics are not the result of
genetic modification at the hands of the
celestials it is but it isn't instead
what they're saying is that it's excess
deviation that in effect what seems to
have happened is that in the early days
of human history a deviant banged a
human and when that happened they popped
out somebody that had a blend between
human and deviant genes and what that
meant is that where excess deviation in
relation to deviance means that deviants
undergo what's called quote unquote the
change where they just kind of turn into
like some grotesque monster version of
themselves that when humans undergo the
deviant change they develop powers right
cyclops's eyes turn into portals to
another dimension full of energy jean
grey can read minds and move stuff and
nightcrawler can teleport that's how
those things work right that's how this
excess deviation basically works in
relation to humanity now take that
concept and roll it over into the mcu
what do we know about thanos what do we
know about the origin of thanos we know
virtually nothing all we know is that
thanos was part of a group of god-like
beings that existed on titan and he told
them hey there's too many of us and
there's not enough resources we got to
like wipe out half of us so that we can
let allow those who continue to exist to
move on without having to die of
starvation until such a time as you
morons decide you want to overpopulate
again and then we got to start the whole
process all over again that's all we
really know and that his race ultimately
ignored him the entire society collapsed
and that was the end of that thanos took
it as essentially a verification that
his ideology was true he took off into
the universe formed his own coal
obsidian and literally just started
manually killing off half the population
of every world until he found the
infinity stones and then snapped his
fingers and did it in one fell swoop
done and done now let's look at the
character of eros right eros isn't
eternal what do we know about the
eternals the eternals are not the result
of genetic modification by the hands of
the celestials they were created by the
celestials they are inorganic they're
basically robots and eros is no
different from that now there was an
interview that chloe zhao had done where
she had basically talked about the
ending of the eternals film and talked
about the nature of eros and the
question was if eros is the brother of
thanos but thanos is not a robot then
how do we square that circle and the
response of chloe zhao is eros is an
eternal in the same way that like ajax
and and icarus and all them are eternals
he's not biological he is a robot the
difference is that he was stationed on
titan just like any other group of
eternals across the universe by the
celestials and he was brought into the
royal family and became the adoptive
brother of thanos he's not his
biological brother and so with that in
mind now we know that thanos at least is
on a genetic level thanos and eros stand
apart that answers the question of how
can an eternal be related to a
biological being if the eternals are
robots having said that
here's what i think happened and here's
here's what i think the origin is of
thanos in the mcu and here is why i
think the mutant population is not
confined to earth that there are mutants
all across the universe and thanos was
one of them what i think happened was
this that the story that we're told in
terms of the deviance in the eternals
film that's the broad strokes right it's
just like here's the whole history of
humanity we were created and we did some
stuff and then yada yada
but it's the broad strokes it doesn't
show the nuances for every rule there's
an exception to the rule so sure
deviance as a race in general basically
ended up starting out destroying all the
different apex predators of worlds then
became apex predators themselves and
then basically became ultra violent
which led to the formation of the
eternals to destroy the deviants and
then the eternals taking over the role
of safeguarding the different races
across the world but there has to be an
exception to that that by whatever
manner and whatever means it's
inevitable that not every single deviant
across the entirety of the universe is
some ultra violent being that exists out
there so is it that far outside the
realm of possibility to believe that on
titan there were deviants and one of
those deviants did not become ultra
violent and one of those deviants
basically slept with whatever that race
happened to be on titan which is not an
offshoot of the eternals it may just be
a race that just evolved there on their
own and that led to the introduction of
deviant genes to the titan population
which is where you get thanos from it
would explain why it is that like so
many of these different beings all
basically look the same but then thanos
suddenly looks different it works that
way in marvel comics all the time you
have a group called the morlocks right
99 of mutants that exist in marvel
comics on earth look like humans the one
percent are the morlocks they usually
end up taking residents under the in the
sewers of new york city you do have
exceptions like people like nightcrawler
or something like that but most all
mutants look like human beings it's just
kind of one of the caveats of the mutant
population of marvel comics is how they
make them relatable to the average
reader so it's not outside the realm of
possibility that deviant genes were just
passed down from one generation to the
next and by random chance or whatever
the case happens to be thanos is just
the deviant that happened to look
different even in marvel comics in
thanos's own history that's the case
right that like literally he possesses a
deviant gene and most of the eternals
possess a deviant gene because it was
just passed on from one eternal to the
next we're literally told that in the
story or at least that's alluded to in
the story and then thanos just looks
different so it's not that far outside
the realm of possibility that thanos is
a member of this race that exists on
titan but he just looks different
because his deviant gene physically
manifested that's why he appears the way
he does but at his core unlike marvel
comics where at his core thanos is a
human in the marvel cinematic universe
he was a mutant right it would explain
why he was so large it would explain his
excess physical strength how he was able
to overpower somebody like the
incredible hulk he is a non-gem powered
version of juggernaut from the x-men
comics tell me i'm wrong right the
juggernaut's gone toe-to-toe physically
with the incredible hulk multiple times
he's got a healing factor all that kind
of stuff thanos is he's very
juggernaut-esque in terms of how he
functions now under normal circumstances
you would just chalk that up to his
genealogy but if you throw in the idea
that mutants basically come into
existence whenever it is that a deviant
procreates with a particular individual
of a normal what you would consider to
be a human-like race then it makes
perfect sense that thanos would
basically be a mutant you take that and
you apply it to earth let's say for
example that of all the deviants that
exist out there right crow was not your
normal deviant he wasn't just
arbitrarily destroying things and even
it seems the explanation that we get
about deviants and eternals may not
actually be true because the explanation
comes by way of the eternals themselves
and the eternals are programmed so
literally they're giving us the origin
of the deviants as it was put in their
programming and that's basically it but
it's not outside the realm of
possibility that some deviant out there
banged some human and that led to the
introduction of deviant genes into the
human gene pool walk away with this idea
of what marvel's doing in judgment day
and that the development of mutant
powers is just the human equivalent of
the change that deviants undergo because
of excess deviation it makes perfect
sense and that may very well be our
introduction of mutants in the mcu for
me like nothing else fits maybe it is
just kind of some arbitrary evolutionary
change right somewhere along the line
just something clicked in the human gene
pool and now they've all got powers but
if they really want to tie thanos and
and deviants and all this kind of stuff
together and marvel comics usually
follows in line with the mcu unlike the
way it used to be it used to be the
marvel cinematic universe followed the
comics now it's the other way around
because marvel comics follows the mcu
this kind of makes sense it makes sense
that what we're getting here with thanos
is that he's basically a mutant among
his own people that on earth mutants
came into existence because somewhere
along the line the deviant gene was
introduced to the human gene pool and
that's where mutants come from by
whatever man and whatever means they're
just now activating or at least as we're
aware of they could have been activating
all this time just popping up and it
would take somebody like xavier to start
organizing them into a team that we call
the x-men and you just kind of go from
there but let me know what you guys
think right do you guys think there's a
solid chance that this is true this is
the way this is working and going
forward in the mcu that the mutant
population or mutants as we know them
are not strictly confined to earth that
they're actually all over the place
across the universe let me know what you
guys think thank you all for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace